a direct attack on the First Amendment
disgraceful election interference
indefensible now those are just some of
the reactions I got today from Judge
Tanya Chin's ruling partially granting
the government's motion for a gag order
that orders former president Trump
essentially don't vilify special counsel
Jack Smith prosecutors Court staff
during the course of his trial over the
events surrounding January 6 so what was
her reasoning well saying his
presidential candidacy does not give him
cart blanch to Villa public servants who
are simply doing their job also noting
that he doesn't have unfettered First
Amendment rights today a judge put on a
gag order I'll be the only politician in
history that runs with a gag order where
I'm not allowed to criticize people can
you imagine this do you believe this I'm
not allowed to criticize people so we'll
see we'll appeal
it Jo I me now all weisenberg former
deputy independent counsil Fox News
contributor as well as David shown
former Trump impeachment lawyer Saul um
you know the judge did say look the
president has broad discretion to talk
about what he wants but you can't you
can't CR basically you can't
criticize Smith and his staff what about
this well I haven't seen the order yet
as as we uh went to the air I hadn't
seen a written order yet so she has hold
on Saul she hasn't released it yet I
know you always do your homework so I KN
you know you would never show up
unprepared David definitely wouldn't but
no she hasn't released it yet we're
going to get into that in a moment but
th those are the broad Strokes of what
she
said yeah and I think she's got to be
very careful because uh there is a
assuming that Trump can find a vehicle
to appeal an interlocutory appeal or
even a challenging it with an injunction
uh if she if she does this too broadly
it's going to be overturned uh at a at a
higher level and also it will delay the
trial which she definitely doesn't want
to do and and president Trump does want
to do I mean David the judge again this
was this was orally the written ORD is
going to come out later warned Trump
against launching what she called a
pre-trial smear campaign against those
who might testify against him saying the
First Amendment protections yield to the
administration of justice and to the
protection of witnesses and she said she
would consider sanctions David if she
sees any violations but then went on to
say elaborate on what those would
be in her written order which hasn't
come out yet so David there's a lot
there I think she's absolutely wrong uh
I think for a number of reasons I think
it's a frontal attack on the first fifth
and sixth amendments I think that part
of her justification she said well he's
a criminal defendant criminal defendants
can't say what they want who says so
he's a citizen of the United States
criminal defendant is entitled The
presumption of innocence under inray
Winship that means he's not guilty of
anything he's entitled to challenge the
process and the sub
uh publicly and quite frankly the
Supreme Court said in genti versus State
Bar of Nevada the process doesn't begin
inside the courtroom and the defendant
is entitled to present his Public Image
as he wishes I believe uh he's perfectly
entitled to say Jack Smith is a thug
he's entitled to question Jack Smith's
character his judgment in bringing past
cases that shouldn't have been brought I
have a sanctions motion against two of
the members of Jack Smith's team right
now their behavior is thuggish JP Cooney
and Molly Gaston they lied to a federal
judge it's in the motion papers
indisputable and so I think he's
entitled to say it I think what she has
done is an affront to our fundamental
core values of free speech uh Saul to
the point that David just raised so
Trump's lawyer and judge shutkin traded
you know barbs back and forth in the
courtroom chuin read aloud a series of
statements from Trump repeatedly raising
concerns that his remarks could Inspire
violence if you call certain people
thugs enough times doesn't that suggest
Mr Laro that some someone should get
them off the streets she asked at one
point so wow that's kind of a that she's
really uh you know you know trying to
prognosticate violence which leads me to
say what else could be uh what else
could how else could the order be you
know be applied that's I mean if
violence could happen I mean that's a
pretty broad
statement I absolutely agree with
David's analysis you know you treat a
prosecutor who's a big boy and should
put his big boy pants on differently
than you then you treat a potential
witness everybody knows you can't uh you
can't threaten or try to intimidate a
potential witness uh the prosecutor he
he produced a speaking indictment he
went to the grand jury and got a ham
sandwich speaking indictment that was
very prejudicial to former president
Trump so he he does that indictment he
holds a press conference and says uh
nobody is above the law we treat
everybody equally and then Trump isn't
allowed to criticize them him so I think
it is outrageous if the mere criticism
of the prosecution team uh is to be is
to be prohibited very different though
when you're talking about a witness yeah
yeah this is third world I mean he's
campaigning in part is he not David on
the fact that the system itself has
become so corrupted with political bias
that we can't trust this system that's
part of his his argu argument in his
campaign so now he can't information as
Saul said and he's absolutely right
there's this speaking indictment out
there with detailed allegations unproven
allegations memorialized everyone can
pull them off their computer anytime any
day but Trump can't respond to that by
challenging the process and the nature
of the people who put him in that
position and Saul on the media you know
corporate media today they were saying
well they were salivating on the fact
that the judge could put Trump in jail
down the road if she believes that he's
violating this gag order purposely
violating the gag order and vilifying
Jack Smith and his Mary band of
prosecutors
well is she going to provide separate
sleeping quarters for the Secret Service
Laura I mean she's not going to do that
uh you know she's uh she's she's going
to do everything possible to avoid that
uh but David made another point about
the the leading Supreme Court uh
decision on this case which is about 30
or 40 years old and is a terrible
opinion with three or four different uh
rule you know opinions by the Supreme
Court uh but it it limited the right of
lawyers the lawyers in the case to say
certain things to the Press not the
criminal defendant and now that's an
important distinction uh it's much more
serious to limit the rights of the
criminal defendant as David points out
he's Presumed Innocent under our system
the one thing he can't do is intimidate
potential Witnesses this I've never seen
anything like this in all my years law
politics this is the wildest thing Saul
David great to see you both thanks